welcome back in Allen Milburn's
resignation letter he praised the
Education Secretary's commitment to the
cause of social mobility but continued
it has become obvious that the
government as a whole is unable to
commit to the same level of support in
the Secretary of State for education is
of course just in greening who joins me
now from Westminster very good morning
to you miss grayling morning how are you
very very well it indeed I'm wondering
about you though I mean you've made
social mobility your top priority today
your social mobility Commission resigned
on mass saying there is little hope of
this government making progress there
are wringing endorsements aren't there
and then there's Alan Milburn well I'm
sorry that Alan's taken the actually
saying his term had come to an end
actually so we just want to make sure we
get some fresh talent into the social
mobility Commission but I agree with him
how important this area is it's a huge
passion for me within the department for
education to really drive social
mobility to drive a quality of
opportunity but I don't agree with Alan
on is the fact that we are doing a huge
amount across government so whether it's
in my own department where we're seeing
school standards getting better last
week we heard that 1.9 million more
children are in better primary and
secondary schools now than in 2010
whether it's looking at the technical
education reforms that were bringing
through and T levels really mobilizing
business to give more opportunities to
young people on their doorsteps there's
a massive amount going on across
government you look at the budget the
week before last on housing stamp duty
cut for first-time buyers actually we're
doing a lot to make sure that young
people can get on the right track and
then make the most of their potential so
there's a long way to go and this isn't
a country where we have equality of
opportunity but we're setting about
making sure that over time we put that
in place for the first time sure so you
weren't then personally pushing for Alan
Milburn's and term as chairman to be
extended well I'm not going to get into
the discussion that sounds like a yes
that sounds like a yes to me
well Alan's term had come to an end so I
think what's important to me is we get
some fresh blood in but I think I'm also
saying that I don't agree that we're not
taking significant steps across
government because we absolutely are and
we're seeing the
fruit of that effort already bearing
results so if you look at the attainment
gap in other words the difference
between how well more disadvantaged
children do compared to their better
starting peers actually that's closing
now in school so we're moving in the
right direction but as Alan sets out
today quite rightly there's a very long
way to go and we need to really make
sure that the fruits of these reforms
are being felt in the communities where
we need to see change happen the most a
long way to go is putting it one women
mister over and said this it's
understand the government is
understandably focused on brexit it does
not seem to have the necessary bandwidth
to ensure that the rhetoric of healing
social division is matched with the
reality I mean Teresa may made that
speech on the doorstep of number 10 in
which she puts social mobility at the
center of her government I'm told that
you had that framed and mounted and on
the walls of your office I mean is that
hanging slightly crooked today no I did
I don't think so
I agree with Alan that we've got a long
long way to go but you look at the
announcement we're making today on
mental health tackling one of the main
barriers actually that often holds about
young people from doing their best and
and reaching their potential more
investment to really support mental
health provision both inside but also
alongside schools more training for for
schools in terms of being able to take
preventative action to help young people
if they have the beginning of a mental
health challenge but set it in the
border context I think we are moving in
the right direction there's a lot of
work going on look at the opportunity
areas work where the Department of
Education is on the ground working
inside schools to improve standards but
also with communities and businesses to
raise aspirations and and set sights
high there's a huge amount of work going
on it is a generational challenge
there's no doubt about this I don't
think any of us should accept a country
where you have a different shot at being
successful purely because of where
you're growing up or your background we
don't fix that overnight but I think
we're moving in the right direction
indeed I mean as you said a generational
challenge maybe we should say of course
the Conservatives have been in power
since 2010 and and frankly much of what
has been said today could have been said
you know back in 2010 about about the
social mobility however I mean the
reason that mr. Milburn gives and he
says it's understand
is that there is a focus in government
on brexit with conservatives no minority
with people under the age of 45 I mean
do you think the Tories have got a
fundamental problem with selling the
PM's take on brexit to the public well I
think she's about to go to Brussels for
an important negotiation later later
this month but actually for me I think
brexit is an enabler to how we make sure
that there's opportunity everywhere for
young people I think it really is
focusing Minds not only within
government on why we need to make sure
that we're unlocking the potential of
every single person in our country but
also business we held a skill summit in
the Department for Education only last
Thursday about how we can make sure that
business is really partnering with
government to offer the opportunities
that young people want on our doorsteps
and if we're going to plug the skills
gap that we've got that we've had for
many many years in this country it will
take not just the reforms to policy on
introducing tea levels and
apprenticeships but also businesses
coming with us on that journey to really
be part of the solution for young people
and I think we have got some way to go
but I really do feel the building blocks
of there now will only achieve this
equality of opportunity that I want to
see in our country if people can work
together and focus on that common name
someone who also has a distance to go if
he wants to get here that is is the u.s.
president Donald Trump should he be
afforded a state visit with all the
trappings given what what he has done
this week which is in essence amplifying
the views and public profile of a
far-right fascist organization well I
think everybody said by and large that
President Trump was wrong to retweet but
should he have a state visit well I
think we need to see it in the context
actually of the broader relationship our
two countries have America and the
United Kingdom
you can visit without you can visit
without meeting the Queen as my points
well there's a real I was going to say
there's a real longevity to it
I think presidents come and go and we
should focus on the the broader picture
of that important relationship the the
fact that America is one of our greatest
allies but we should also reflect on the
fact that whatever you may think
anyone's personal view of President
Trump he's the elected
head of the American of the US so I
think it's important that we maintain a
relationship with America with the
United States we don't agree with the
the tweets that he did over the past
several days and we've made that very
clear
um yes I mean some behavior can can be
categorized as wrong I mean included
within that one presumes is viewing
pornography at work I don't think that's
acceptable I don't think most employers
would think it's acceptable and of
course there are clear laws around the
nature of viewing pornography more
generally um but in terms of Damien
green actually let's stick with a
hypothetical because we know mr.
Greene's position in all of this and
what would be the internal procedure at
your department of a member of your
staff was was find access and
pornography well there are clear rules
for all employers including the public
services so those would kick into action
as they would with any question around
employee disciplinary procedures I mean
that the question now is whether or not
your cabinet colleague has lie doesn't
it I mean his close ally Crispin but
made the same point on Friday I mean if
he is proved to have lied about any of
this no and this is actually inserted
entirely in fact separate to the issue
of watching pornography at work if he is
proved to lie he has to go doesn't he
well there's a cabinet office review
into all of this under way I don't think
it's either helpful or particularly
sensible of me to preempt what that will
come out with so there's not anything to
sing if mr. green has been clear about
his stance on this and he's made that
clear in the past and I'm sure Damien
will continue to be to be firm in in
what he said just in greeting lovely to
see it thanks very much for being with
us thank you